oh oh
sommes-nous sur ouais oh autour ouais fais-moi
rire
souvenir
[Rires]
et quand j'y pense le lendemain ça
me fait aimer deux fois plus
toi
alors qu'est-ce que tu vas falsifier maintenant parce que t'as
presque tout falsifié il ne reste plus rien
il ne reste plus rien
peut-être que je parodie je me moque de wall street
ouais oui tu es l'année prochaine à propos de l'argent de wall
street l'
argent l'argent c'est ce qu'est la vie
l'argent l'argent l'argent
il n'y a pas de valeur tu sais il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas de valeurs humaines
c'est un bon très bon titre dans
france qu'est-ce que ce serait
en france tout le monde peut comprendre
personne
et pourquoi les critiques américains ne t'aiment pas
pourquoi
parce que je suis nul parce que je les déteste
tu es d'accord je peux les détester oh je déteste
arrêter ne mentionne pas le mot critique d'
accord jamais  dis critique et merci
ils t'aiment
la banque s'en fout eh bien les banquiers
parce que ton film a beaucoup de succès
aux états les gens ils m'aiment
ouais mais quand les films passent ouais ils
ne t'aiment pas ils ne m'aiment plus
tellement maintenant
et  pouvez-vous expliquer ouais pouvez-vous expliquer l'
humour juif je peux expliquer l'humour juif en
buvant du champagne non je ne peux pas expliquer
ouais tu préfères non pourquoi les affaires de pascal
tu ne veux pas te donner ton
secret
non non parce que
ouais le secret de l'humour juif  ils le
feront
même s'ils sont des fantômes s'ils ne sont pas
juifs ils peuvent gagner de l'argent en regardant la
série
ou goyim beaucoup d'entre vous beaucoup de juifs ouais d'
accord alors vous n'expliquez pas non non
j'explique parce que
je ne sais pas  ok explique explique le
secret
de juif de l'humour juif c'est le secret de l'
humour juif
c'est la peur si tu as peur
tout le temps tu es debout tu es conscient
tu es un peu
psychotique tu es un peu tu vois ce que
je veux dire  paranoïaque ouais
paranoïa tu ressembles et tu es toujours
excité et tes yeux sont grands ouverts
et tu es drôle ouais donc tu dois avoir
peur d'être drôle
ouais si tu es détendu calme tu ne
dis pas que
tu ne vas pas bien et explique  moi pourquoi seuls les
juifs peuvent se
moquer et aimer les juifs
parce que nous sommes toujours afr  aide on est
toujours
de la persécution ouais donc il faut rire
ouais tu te concentres
tu parles très bien français merci et tu
parles
un anglais
terrible  très bien
oui je pense humour humour yuma aussi oui
les frères max les frères marx
einstein et les frères freud et euh
comment as-tu commencé dans la vie ah
[Rires]
mais mes premières impressions la première
tu fais la démonstration ouais je vais tout te montrer
d'accord mais juste pour peigner
ouais c'était juste un petit stylo
j'avais l'habitude de faire deux couches
hitler le prochain
staline lenin
hiawatha groucho marx
valentino je veux dire j'ai dit ne jamais tout voir
et ensuite tu décides
[Rires]
avant ça j'étais musicien tu sais
ouais  tu sais avant que j'entre dans le show
business et puis tu
as écrit max lemon ass non non je l'ai fait ouais
henry ouais et puis tu travaillais
avec woody allen
je travaillais cesaro oui avec woody
allen et
vos voies sont divisées je travaillais
ouais ouais
travaillais ouais
oui je travaillais avec Woody
ouais et parfois je marchais en marchant
absolument
divisé toi toi oui
ma carrière est divisée mon esprit est divisé
tout est divisé
tu es le patron du film de brooke je suis
le  le propriétaire et le patron
mais vos films sont très populaires et
Woody va vers des
choses très intimes vous savez la
paix et vous voulez en manger c'est
très c'est très bien d'être le roi
qu'est-ce que c'est 1918 qu'est-ce que c'est c'est un
champagne que vous demandez
et  tu payes pour ça je peux fumer oui oh
s'il te plaît euh si tu fumes tu meurs tu sais ça ouais
mais s'il
te plaît tu ne fumes pas non je ne sens pas c'est
pourquoi ton film parle de plus frais
mon film parle d'air frais c'est c'est un
c'est  tout sur le
président skrube ouais tu es ouais ouais
président ouais et j'utilise toute l'année
ouais ouais
je
princesse juive oui druide juif
que pensez-vous de la monarchie parce que
vous avez dû manger avec elle c'est très agréable
d'être le roi d'
Israël le roi de  Etats-Unis  reagan non non non
non c'est pas non non c'est le bouffon
et si à l'époque il était acteur
tu l'
aurais entendu
il était le pire mais tu sais même quand
tu fais une comédie ouais quand tu sens une
communauté
il faut prendre le  série comique
ouais et parfois pas
personnel pas les acteurs ont pris leurs rôles
très sérieux masculin rosemont
john candy ouais il est
sur la chaîne le euh doug je suis chien
chien ouais john candy
et il est devenu un chien ouais
avant de voir les troisièmes clips
ouest ouest  sur noir sur noir s'il vous plait entrée d'
accord avant de voir le troisième clip oui
sur la planète des singes pouvez vous me poser
une question
s'il vous plait je vous pose des questions ouais je
vous pose 20 questions s'il vous plait posez moi une
question
soyez gentil avec moi êtes vous êtes vous  heureux de
faire le spectacle je suis très heureux d'être avec
toi
est-ce qu'ils te paient bien ils ne
me paient pas tant que ça mais je suis très heureux
de
non mais non mais comment ça se sent maintenant non je
me sens
très bien très très  grand
grand sûr que je suis très je suis très heureux d'être
ici mais est-ce un problème si je suis  pas
juif
c'est un gros business dans le show business alors
tu penses que je dois arrêter
non non non non non non non continuer à attendre
si je change de nom non je pourrais
tu penses que je peux devenir juif et ensuite
je t'expliquerai peux tu prendre
je peux prendre  douleur maximale d'accord d'
accord ça fait mal et maintenant nous verrons le
troisième clip
la planète des singes le troisième clip tu te
souviens nous avons déjà eu deux clips
non tu as déjà eu deux clips oh je vraiment
oh bon et maintenant nous verrons le troisième
merci  toi
pour le
merci tu es merveilleux vraiment tu es
merveilleux merci maintenant
le dernier clip tournons ton clip ouais
la pince à billets tu ne démarres pas
ça ne démarre pas non non je ne sais pas pourquoi
ça prend du temps  le temps c'est bon
viens juste apprendre le tableau des événements du film et
hester
lemon shot
hey
[Music]
blue